this is my favorite article this is
truly my favorite article that i have
seen in months it's from npr
headline outrage as a business model
how ben shapiro is using facebook to
build an
empire i'll read you just the first
paragraph or so here
in 2021 ben shapiro rules facebook
the conservative podcast host and
author's personal facebook page has more
followers than the washington post
and he drives an engagement machine
unparalleled by anything else on the
world's biggest social networking site
an npr analysis of social media data
found that over the past year stories
published by the site shapiro found in
the daily wire
received more likes shares and comments
on facebook than any other news
publisher
by a wide margin even legacy news
organizations that have broken major
stories or produced groundbreaking
investigative work don't come anywhere
close
i'd like to translate this article for
you if you want if you want to know
the subtext of this article it's this
headline
first paragraph wow
no the daily wire is good at what they
do
people want to read it uh they don't
trust us anymore but they do trust
shapiro and knowles and cleveland and
boring and walsh
what i
love it so first of all they're seeding
to us
that we are way better at talking to
people than they are
and they they grant to us that people
are more inclined to
believe what we have to say than what
they have to say and to engage in
what we're talking about than what what
they're talking about but here's what
they say it's outrage
and they go on and they cite a bunch of
lib professors and things like that and
they say
they're monetizing outrage and hate and
anger
so first of all we don't i think i
actually think this is a rather
reasonable balanced program
you know we make fun of them obviously
but we tell you exactly what point of
view we're coming from
i like to think that we also present the
best arguments from the other side and
then explain why they're
stupid arguments but compared to cnn
compared to msnbc compared to the new
york times i think we do way more of
that i think we are way more fair
than any of those guys are and by the
way they generally speaking won't even
come out
with their biases right cnn says facts
first
facts we're a banana we're an apple
banana the new york times all the news
that's fit to print it's really all the
news that fits the narrative
they say oh i'm so depressed by this
it's terrible when i went
are you telling me that cnn doesn't
focus on outrage
cnn for the trump presidency had a covid
death count that was constantly going
you don't really see that quite so much
under the biden administration
cnn the new york times the washington
post would just make up stories they
would just make them up about donald
trump colluding with the russkies
remember that they would sensationalize
stories about donald trump with
prostitutes in moscow
based on nothing completely made up to
gin up outrage
daily wire has never done anything like
that the daily wire
does not monetize outrage
anywhere in the same stratosphere as the
new york times and cnn
and the washington post and npr
apparently
and and by the way when we do focus on
outrages
they are legitimate outrages not totally
cooked up contrived nonsense but npr
very upset
why is the daily wire successful is it
because we're so handsome
and so wonderful and so great i like to
think so but you know what you know what
i actually think it is and i say this
with no false modesty i think the reason
that the daily wire is doing better in
terms of engagement with real people
is because the establishment media blew
their credibility and they lied to the
people and they lied lied lie gladly and
eventually the people stopped paying
attention
and then the daily wire has done our
best to get it right and you know
sometimes we get it wrong like everyone
sometimes gets it wrong but we haven't
just lied and pushed
a liberal establishment propaganda
proved a message
down your throats constantly and so
people respond well to that
certainly on the right but also in the
middle and even some people who are on
the left
that's what i think they're really
they're not upset at ben shapiro and
they're not upset at the rest of us at
the daily wire
if they are it's misplaced they should
be upset with themselves
for tarnishing their own credibility the
proof
of this thesis the proof that i'm right
about this is that outside of the media
in elected politics
democrats in rural areas are not even
acknowledging that they're democrats
anymore
i'm glad you like that clip i want you
to watch the whole show the title of
which is the bill comes
due check it out on apple pocket spotify
stitcher google play
here on youtube ring the bell like
subscribe
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you